[Музика]
привіт, привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія Оскар, давайте
почнемо,
і сьогодні наша тема буде моєю
останньою поїздкою, давайте,
так що це моє фото так,
країна, де це так,
це не Туреччина  і назва цього
місця -
Стамбул, давайте подивимося, що я зробив
,
тому минулого лютого ми поїхали до Стамбула
на вихідні, у нас був прямий рейс з
Києва, коли ми потрапили до Стамбула, ми
каталися на велосипедах, хоча було досить
холодно  вечорами не було зимою,
ми їли смачну турецьку їжу,
моя мама купила турецький шарф, і я
зробив багато фотографій, ми чудово провели час, тому,
як бачите, я розповідаю вам про свою останню
поїздку попередній досвід
Сьогодні ми поговоримо про граматику, а наша тема –
минулий простий час, давайте ще раз подивимося
на текст у термінах минулого
простого часу, тому минулого лютого ми поїхали в
Стамбул на вихідні, чи знаєте ви, коли
це сталося, так, ми бачимо світ у лютому минулого
року  означає, що це було в минулому в
точний час тому, коли у нас фіксований час
і дія була в минулому, ми
використали past simple давайте подивимося ще на
одне речення у нас був прямий рейс
з Києва, тому слово had тут ми називаємо
irregular, тому давайте подивимося  у
реченні, хоча було досить холодно,
не було відчуття, що зима, як
ви бачите, не подобається, як це
слово є правильним, тому давайте подивимося
на ці дві речі тут: неправильні та
правильні дієслова, але перш за все давайте
почнемо з деяких  потренуйтеся
використовувати фрази зі списку, щоб сказати, що
робили чи ні твої друзі минулих вихідних, тож
давайте подивимося на приклад сашко
не грав у футбол
він дивився відео онлайн давайте
подивимося ще один приклад, щоб Іванка
зварила макарони  тепер твоя черга,
ти можеш дати мені приклади, можеш ввести
їх у коментарях або надіслати нам
повідомлення давайте подивимося, наприклад, піти
на вечірку, що ти можеш зробити,
яке речення, наприклад, Наталка пішла
на вечірку чи Солана?  не ходити на
вечірку, це добре  давайте подивимося ще на
один приклад, наприклад, мені подобається
гуляти з собакою, вигулювати собаку, тому мій
батько вигулював собаку, тому що моя мама
не любить вигулювати собаку, вона не
витримує цього, давайте йти далі, скажімо, що сьогодні час граматики,
і ми  ми говоримо про
минулий простий час, скажіть слова-тригери
для вас, коли ми маємо вчора або останній
понеділок, останню неділю, вівторок минулого
літа тиждень тому або день тому або місяць тому
в 2015 році, це все було в минулому, і ми
відразу розуміємо, що це  чи є
минуле просте, тож коли ви бачите це слово,
маєте речення в минулому простому, зараз
давайте поговоримо про утворення, як ми
складаємо речення, давайте почнемо з
позитивного, а це регулярне дієслово
утворення сказати позитивне речення він
грав у теніс ми додаємо  кінець оголошення
давайте підготуємо негативний він не грав у
регбі, тому, як ви бачите, ми змінили
II D у нас його більше немає, ми
просто пишемо play no plate this is wrong
і додаємо дієслово
did this є допоміжним дієсловом  для
простого минулого  тому ще раз позитив він
грав у теніс негативний він не грав у
теніс і це звичайні дієслова, тож
давайте трохи потренуємося з правилами правопису,
дієслова різні, тому ми
пишемо їх по-різному, давайте почнемо
з додавання та в IDI, а дієслово закінчується на
E, тому ми не подвоїмо e, ми просто додаємо закінчення D,
прибув прибув, давайте розглянемо
ще один приклад,
тому вивчіть, коли дієслово закінчується на Y і
перед цим є константа, ми
змінюємо Y на I і EDD, тому вивчено
добре, давайте  спробуйте з іншими прикладами грати,
це також закінчується на y,
але перед Y є голосний без
приголосного, тому ми просто додаємо рекламу, гра
відтворюємо, давайте рухатися по світу зупинено,
вона закінчується на приголосний перед ним
є голосний, а приголосний знову
стосується голосного  приголосний, ось чому нам
потрібно подвоїти останній приголосний, а
потім зупинка TD, а остання,
коли слово закінчується на L і є
голосний перед цим, ми подвоємо цю L, а
потім під час подорожі IDI
давайте потренуємося  давайте йти,
тому я підготую для вас гру, і
ось список звичайних дієслів, які ми
збираємося змінити на минуле, у
нас є 16 чисел, скажімо, я збираюся використовувати
два кубика, перш за все, у цього є
чотири
чисел, а цей має 12 чисел,
тож 4 плюс 12 скільки це 16, тож якщо у мене є 16
мені потрібно кинути ще раз, і тому, коли я к
ну два кубики, у мене буде два та ві
ім, тож давайте потренуємося в наших математичних навичках 8 п
юс 2  це 10,
хм, 10 – це почати те, що є минулим простим
для нього так, почніть, тому давайте грати готові
до кубиків, я збираюся кинути це, і у нас є
7 і 4 7 плюс 4 так 11, тому 11 змивається,
що є минулим простим чотири  вимитий і
він вимитий дозвольте мені записати це 11
вимитий вимитий скажімо давайте спробуємо ще раз давайте
спробуємо ще раз у нас є 4 і 12 це знову рулет у
нас є 10 і 4 10 плюс 4 14 і
14 є готувати 14 готувати і минуле просте
для нього
так приготовлено давайте спробуємо ще раз два кубика
готові до кидання У мене є 9 і 4 9 і 4
разом 13 те, що 13 відкрито, так відкрито
в минулому, просто йде
відкривається, щоб ви могли спробувати вдома і пограти
зі своїми батьками або своїми братами і сестрами, якщо
вам не потрібно грати в кубики, ви просто використовуєте
звичайний кубик із шістьма числами, але
кидайте його двічі,
а потім прокоментуйте свій досвід,
вибачте.
у нас є речення, і нам потрібно
заповнити пропуски,
допоможи мені перша Джейн
ла ля ля відвідає Шотландію, і у нас
є робота, хочеться в минулому. Просто
буде розшук Джейн хотіла відвідати
Шотландію номер два
вона запросила Лізу піти  з її номером
3 вони зупиняються в готелі в минулому,
вони заявляють, що в готелі номер чотири Джейн,
поїздка вниз за останнім детальним
планом допомогла мені зі словом, запланованим у минулому,
тому Джейн Планта подорожує до
останньої деталі
номер п'ять, куди вони їдуть  Шотландія
поїздом у минулому подорожували, будь ласка, зверніть
увагу, коли ми Double L номер шість
вони пробують місцеві страви в минулому просто
вони пробували місцеві страви, і останній з них
їм подобається подорож у минулому, їм
подобається подорож Браво
зараз завдання для вас швидко  запишіть
речення, і через десять секунд
я перевірю вас
добре, тому правильні відповіді
номер два ми зупинялися в чудовому готелі
біля моря минулого літа, номер 3,
як тільки вони прибули до
Лондона, номер чотири, ви відвідали Рим  минулого
року правильно розкажи мені про це номер п'ятий
Джон пішов до музею номер шість ми
дивилися фільм минулої суботи вдень,
а номер сім
Сандра закінчила пакувати валізу
годину тому,
дякую за вашу роботу, зараз давайте поговоримо
про неправильні дієслова, і ми можемо говорити про
вік  про правильні дієслова, тому перш за все
інформаційне позитивне речення, ми більше не
додаємо Еді, ми змінюємо дієслово
повністю, тому він зробив багато
фотографій, а заперечне речення він
не взяв грошей,
тому ми змінюємо дієслово з talk на take
і ми не мали зараз, давайте подивимося
на ці приклади, тому надішліть у сьогодення
в минуле надіслане номер, щоб розбити
три, випийте випийте
номер чотири, подивіться, щоб номер п'ять зробив,
але номер шість подумав  t номер сім
біг біг
номер вісім може добре,
а номер дев'ять принесіть і десять
напишіть написали, тому перевірте правопис, чи
є у вас те саме чи інше, тепер настав час
для неправильного дієслова gymnastics do like
gymnastics давайте трохи потренуємося скажімо,
це буде цікаво  фізична
перерва, і ви пам’ятаєте, що з
неправильними дієсловами ми маємо три форми
інфінітиву минулого простого
і минулого дієприкметника, тож давайте уявімо,
що в першому стовпці інфінітив – це
руки вгору, як В, були минуле просте,
а причастя минулого часу bin B був  were
bin давайте спробуємо з іншим дієсловом do
help me
did done done continue давайте візьмемо
інше дієслово come come come, чому
вони піднялися, тому що перша і
третя форми однакові List again
come come прийти дозвольте мені записати це для вас
ну, це перший, потім прийшов
він інший, тому я використовую його тут,
а третій прийшов знову, подивіться,
приходьте, і тільки другий
інший, тому я використовую differ  ent
дії тож давайте повторимо ще раз come
come come let's go з іншим дієсловом cut and
it's the same cut cut cut can't because
there's the same um let's try have
had have hand because Друга і
третя форми однакові lets go з go
go  Gone Gone Fantastic
Дайте мені ще один приклад із play play
play
Наталія грає не неправильне відрижка, це
звичайне, і це дуже неправильне
дієслово gymnastics, дуже дякую,
давайте продовжуємо писати речення,
використовуючи правильну форму past simple I’m
going  щоб записати слова на дошці,
а ви запишіть у свої зошити, а
потім ми перевіримо добре,
давайте домовимося, тому перше речення Аліса
не вечеряла вчора,
а правильне речення: Аліса
не вечеряла вчора, давайте розглянемо
другий приклад Кевін
купити  some books last Saturday by is
неправильне дієслово past simple for it is
buy so let's go Кевін
Кевін купив декілька книг минулої суботи
давайте поїдемо з наступною я не лягаю
спати пізно вчора ввечері зауважте нег.  допоміжне
речення, тому нам потрібне допоміжне речення, чи
я не ліг спати пізно вчора ввечері
номер чотири, минулих вихідних не було дощу,
примітка знову це негативне речення, тому
мені знову потрібне допоміжне речення, чи не було
дощу минулих вихідних наступне, коли Рейчел
перемогла  the конкуренція минулого тижня win є
неправильним дієсловом past simple for it is
one,
так що Рейчел виграла змагання минулого тижня,
а останній з них вони їдять піцу минулої
неділі я ревную я люблю піцу, тому
це неправильне дієслово, символ минулого для нього
8,
вони їли піцу минулої неділі, тож якщо ми подивимося
на речення ще раз і
проаналізуємо слова-тригери минулої суботи минулої
ночі
минулих вихідних минулого тижня минулої неділі
все в минулому,
давайте перевіримо, правильно чи ні, чи є
у вас те саме, давайте рухатися далі, давайте працювати  з
певною вимовою, коли ми додаємо
суфікс IDI, іноді він вимовляється по-
різному, ми можемо вимовляти його за допомогою
цього порядку, тож давайте подивимося на
правила, за якими він вимовляється is eed, коли
дієслово закінчується на звук порядку, наприклад
w  anted або mended його можна вимовити
, коли дієслово закінчується на K okay sure
sure,
і в цьому випадку ми вимовляємо
суфікс IDI як надто як liked missed watched
washed stoped у всіх інших прикладах, які
ми вимовляємо, коли слово
закінчується на  будь-який інший звук, як-от закритий
вивчив любив, давайте потренуємося,
тож у нас є список дієслів, і нам
потрібно помістити їх у правильний стовпець
вимови, скажімо, почнемо зі мною
цієї години
зіграли прибрано несли відкрито фіксували на
звук сподобалося зупинилися ходили
вимили і  приготований і це звучить запрошено
винайшов хотів почав, тому, будь ласка,
вимовляйте ці дієслова правильно, зараз
час вікторини, і я збираюся перевірити, чи ви
готові, то що Дженні робила минулої неділі,
складіть речення go to the mall
негативне речення так Дженні не пішла
до торгового центру наступне запитання
слухати музику позитивне речення Дженні
слухати музику і ще одне
негативне речення в онлайн-чаті та ще одне
негативне речення в онлайн-чаті
Дженні не перевірила онлайн  тож твоє
домашнє завдання на наступний урок
– це те, що ти робив минулої неділі, напиши
п’ять речень, використовуючи минуле просте, і
я збираюся перевіряти тебе наступного разу,
на жаль, є дзвіночок, тому ми
повинні закінчити урок, до побачення, побачимось
наступного разу
[  Музика]
ти